all right here's the story we got this
ABC 7 New York Police Issue call for
help outrage continues to grow over
deadly Subway Chokehold encounter is it
the death of a Subway Rider who's put
into a Chokehold by a former Marine on
the train has been ruled a homicide and
now activists are calling for charges to
be filed they have planned several
protests and rallies on Thursday as the
NYPD had ish has issued a call for
public help in their investigation
Jordan nearly 30 died from a compression
of the neck the city's medical examiner
determined Wednesday Neely is
recognizable to some New Yorkers as a
Michael Jackson impersonator who
regularly danced in Times Square in the
Times Square Transit Hub on Monday
afternoon he was yelling and pacing back
and forth on an F train in Manhattan
Witnesses and police said when he was
restrained by at least three people
include including a U.S marine veteran
who pulled one arm tightly around his
neck a physical struggle ensued leading
to nearly losing Consciousness he was
rushed to Lenox Hill Hospital where he
was pronounced dead on Wednesday a
medical exam determined Neely's uh his
death was a homicide however that does
not mean the case will be prosecuted as
aham aside okay that's the stupidest bit
of writing I've ever heard as a murderer
they mean homicide means death caused by
person it doesn't mean criminal so what
they're trying to say is though the the
the the death was worldly homicide it
does not mean the case will be
prosecuted as a murder
that is up to the uh Manhattan day's
office which is investigating but I
suppose I'm probably being a little bit
too harsh because you can uh they're not
being clear here you can make the
argument there's Reckless homicide
there's negligent homicide and so what
they're saying is it's not clear that he
will be criminally charged they probably
just should have said
they're going to say as a part of our
rigorous ongoing investigation we'll
review the medical examiner's report
assess all available video and photo
footage identify and interview as many
witnesses as possible and obtain
additional medical records read a
statement from a spokesperson for the
D.A so we've got video coming out of New
York protesters uh I believe this was
yesterday we're uh we're seen in the
streets and the police made some arrests
and uh we'll get into it in a little bit
but one of our reporters
was physically assaulted by one of the
protesters and had his his property
destroyed while he was in the process of
doing journalism but uh uh let's just
let's just get down to brass tacks here
because I'm sure there's gonna be a lot
of arguments about this one this is the
story of a guy who was having a mental
breakdown I guess the news that recently
came out was that he was a Subway
performer and his mental health
collapsed after his uh I think I think
his mom was killed is what they're
reporting and after that he kind of just
lost it and then he had been arrested 40
times he had much once uh punched a 67
year old woman in the face and so as he
was belligerent on the subway reportedly
threatening people saying that he would
take it he was ready to die and he would
hurt people this is when the three men
subdued him the uh reportedly the Marine
told everyone to call 9-1-1 and uh get
the police down there and then he ended
up dying which has resulted in the left
like AOC whether or not people because I
don't know I don't know if you consider
her left but AOC yeah she's Progressive
she said this was a public murder
and now you've got protesters calling
for this guy to be arrested they're
saying he committed a murder and uh I
think this is actually a really good
example of what what is described as
anarcho tyranny in that you had 25
people pushed onto subway tracks in the
past year you've had uh like a woman get
raped on a train in Philadelphia and we
don't hear a single peep from any of
these politicians from any of these
activists until someone actually stops
the guy if you go back seven kills him
right
sure yeah so so when someone is being
violent and then someone else acts in
self-defense of others and the person
dies in the process now there's all of a
sudden calls for okay so this this guy
should be criminally charged but there
was no call for stopping the 25 people
being pushed on the subway tracks that's
that that's an ongoing and acceptable
thing I suppose I'm never going to sit
here and try and defend people pushing
people on the subway tracks that's a
crime like that's terrible attempted
murder yeah exactly especially if they
die so that's horrible No One's Gonna Be
on the other side of that argument but
in terms of like the guy who just got
killed isn't and you can correct me if
I'm wrong on this doesn't in
self-defense the poor like the
proportionality of what you're doing has
to be in response to the actual
aggressive actions of the person right
it has to be proportional is that
correct so you feel in your mind that I
was a proportional response for him to
choke him out to death in that situation
because he was going to become such a
threat to the person but you you stepped
up you made a big leap right there which
what's the lead you're a scribing intent
to the Marine to kill oh I'm not saying
he intended to kill on I never said that
but he did end up killing him right so
well no but what is you're making what
has to be material Tim has to be
originality argument or are you making
yes I'm asking well I'm asking you that
because is proportional to the threat so
the threat that he was going it is
proportional to subdue someone that is
threatening other people and saying
he'll die in the process and and end up
killing him even if that was you so see
see now you're doing it again you're
ascribing Intent no I'm not a scrubbing
intent I'm seeing the results this is
what happened the guy's dead he's dead
right material to the proportionality of
action so the proportionality of action
in your mind was justified to what he
was doing his actual action he held the
guy on the ground well I said call 911
you're doing it again no you keep saying
I'm doing it again I'm saying this is
the end results I'm not saying this is
what he meant to do maybe he didn't I
don't know I don't know what's in his
heart either to you none of us know
if someone is threatening other people
you are allowed to subdue them and then
would it be like an involved
manslaughter so but this is what
happened it's to the point of death so
you have it's not a criminal I'm not
saying to kill him that's the difference
right but if he ended up dying as a
result of that was that proportional yes
he he needed to be killed no or he could
have killed hold on stop that you can't
you keep trying to say needed to be no
no that's what happened that's the end
result you're saying the Marine tried to
kill him no I didn't say that then why
don't you say that why would you put
words in my mouth
needed to be killed because what he did
to him his choke out ended up with a guy
dying so that was the end result so his
proportional response to what he thought
was a threat was that I'm gonna choke
him out I'm not trying to kill him but
I'm going to choke him out whether or
not he dies is going to be something
that we're just going to remain to be on
the cards right this is chance we'll
leave it up the chance so you are making
a huge leap right there there's no way
Tim what he's doing is that proportional
is choking someone with the possibility
of death show with the possibility of
death yes okay okay
let me tell you so if uh someone tried
illegally entering my home sure I will
use whatever Force necessary to stop
them from illegal entering my home and
illegally entering my home right I have
the the legal justification in the state
that I live in to use whatever Force
necessary to stop someone from entering
my home illegally now you can't invite
someone in and there's actually some
some legal barriers here like if someone
actually walks up to your house and the
door is open and they walk in that's
actually not an illegal entry it is to a
certain degree but it's like trespass
it's like your door was open there was
no obstruction and then you'll make an
argument about entering the domicile
could be considered fourth degree
burglary depending on which state you're
in if they actually open the door and
enter they've now committed felony
burglary and you are entitled in West
Virginia to use whatever Force necessary
to stop someone from illegally entering
your house that doesn't mean you just
intend to actually kill someone so in
terms of we're out in the street someone
is threatening someone else you are
legally entitled to subdue them now even
if that sub like even in the act of
doing that you could kill them yes
absolutely absolutely because uh where
you're going with it is like what what
what sub what what act of subduing would
be permitted in your mind then like
holding his hands tightly uh one that
doesn't have a possibility of death I
would say because if it's give me one
and you're and you're and your uh and
your Martial Arts expertise
um zero absolutely okay yeah so there's
nothing and I think I can contend that
no one here has any right all right am I
in a Junior I've just watched a lot of
movies
no but uh sharp elbows but but no none
of us have black belts we don't know
this we're just about people who
talk on the internet going black muscle
up I mean I have hostile environment
training and I have some minimal martial
arts strength minimal minimal minimal I
didn't I've done uh I've done some Kung
Fu Taekwondo so once again there's no
experts here yeah uh so certainly we'll
contend I am not an expert however
if someone is threatening harm against
another person and three people find it
reasonable to subdue him and the person
dies that person was in the process of
committing a crime if you lose your life
in the process of committing a crime I'm
not going to blame the victims for this
right would you blame the victims for
this when you're saying victims you mean
the people who killed them the people
who are being attacked but were they
attacked prior or did they try to subdue
him so do we have do we have footage
before so in New York for example if you
go up to someone and threaten them
you've committed a crime right you've
committed a criminal act of violence
against another person by threatening
them and going up to their face
right and so you're saying at that point
you have the ability to proportionally
respond with so violence yeah actually
there's a there's a video of this uh
myth informed has it seven years ago
this man was called a hero for defusing
Violence by putting another man in a
Chokehold a man in the subway was
getting up in people's faces and he was
threatening them and another man got up
behind him and put him in a Chokehold
and he was put on national television
and he was celebrated as a hero for
doing so so this is what I'm talking
about anarcho tyranny I feel like you're
latching onto this completely from a
point of uh you don't have knowledge on
proper uh technique for subduing an
individual no a lot of us do no the
legal expertise
but see see that that that's kind of an
absurd thing to just outright well well
look I'm gonna say this guy committed a
murder and should go to prison but I'm
not an expert and neither are you
therefore he should I never said that
I'm I'm actually asking questions
because these are things that I don't
fully understand about is it legal for
him to do what he did is it is
proportionately legal yes okay that's
why he wasn't charged he was released
however in this day and age what's
likely going to happen is anako tyranny
people go out in the streets they
protest and the police say for political
reasons we're going to go find this guy
and we're going to arrest him but I
don't know it depends unfortunately we
don't have footage of what happened
before that that's what I'd like to know
but if there's enough people on the
train that are are witness to what was
happening and they're like yo he was
threatening all of us cops are not going
to mess with that and that's what was
reported and there were three men trying
to subdue him as he fought back so
there's there's like there's there's no
debate that this guy was acting
violently and threatening people and
even said he was prepared to die at that
point you have what what could be a
terroristic threat I think I think if a
guy got in a train and screamed I'm
going to cause harm to people and then
said he was willing to die you'd
probably want to stop him because
there's signs all over the subway saying
if you see something say something and I
suppose we could go the route of uh when
when Lou gradkowski had that video there
was a guy in a Subway with a knife
stabbing people and the cop said we're
not going to get involved at all and
then some guy had to try and intervene
himself it's funny that guy's a hero
yeah that was I think oh yeah here it is
Matt Walsh retweeted Alexandra Cortez's
tweet from six hours ago and asking
specifically what are they supposed to
do what are people supposed to do in
this situation are they supposed to sit
there if someone's screaming they're
gonna they're gonna hurt somebody you
just sit there and wait until they
actually hurt the person and then you
respond and I'm just I'm just curious
you know honest question uh we have the
story from the daily mail from October
25 victims have been shoved in front of
subway cars so far this year uh two
victims were killed
where where was the protest
well you know where was the video
footage of it there's video there is
video footage of it is it public yes
public video footage and I'm not I can't
play it on YouTube but yo there's video
footage of people being pushed in front
of trains and and and where's AOC
where's any of these protesters
nowhere to be found an arcot tyranny is
that when the criminals do it as
explained in uh was it sultanitsin the
gulag archipelago when a criminal does
this act in the Soviet Union they didn't
that's just a criminal that's what they
do but when you the citizen defend
yourself you knew better but so you're
blaming EOC for not bringing attention
to this specifically so as in living are
you saying that she's she's hypocritical
because she doesn't talk about the
people being pushed in front of trains
but she's talking about this now I'm not
saying hypocritical no I'm saying my I
have a question of why why now why only
when people are victimized and they
defend themselves are they are we now
upset about what happened victimized
we're talking about a poor homeless
person who attacks may have been having
uh an episode and died in what like
ended up being the struggle that's so
why are the people who were subduing him
victims what what makes these victims he
assaulted them so you have that on
camera that he assaulted them first
according to all the news reports and
the police and the witness statements
can we see the footage I want to see I
haven't seen that yet I think we can
show the choke out okay so according to
the news reports the witnesses and the
police he went and threatened violence
against people which is assault and
right could you see any specifically
threatened violence against the people
who subdued him do we have evidence of
that it's one thing for him to be in a
train being like I'm I'm not winning an
argument here I'm not trying to win an
argument I'm actually pedantic awfully
pedantic yes why would you use pedantic
at this in this form as in like I'm
trying to get to the root of this
problem no no it's absurd to imply that
if a woman if a guy walks up to a woman
and says he's going to harm her that
another man can't protect right and so
this is why I'm asking did he say to the
people who subdue who subdued him I'm
going to harm you yes I'm going to hurt
you that's immaterial to a self-defense
claim and proportionality okay if this
guy was threatening people right and
then someone said I'm going to stop you
before you hurt someone that is legal
self-defense acting in the defense of
others that makes those people who who
are stopping the guy threatening people
the victims of a violent individual who
is trying to cause harm
yeah I just find it fascinating that
there's a there's an effort to defend
the aggressor in this circumstance right
oh so you're suggesting that the guys
even if the guys that were choking out
weren't the ones being threatened that
they're still considered a victim
because they stepped in to defend other
people well I'm saying outright that if
you're on a train and there's a guy
you're on a train you can't get off that
train you are you are trapped yeah right
I used to live in Flatbush I used to I
used to take these trains every single
day I've seen this I've seen this and
worse I've seen people in the middle of
episodes where I was like this person
could potentially either harm themselves
or harm me it never crossed my mind that
I need to choke them out to the point of
potential death in order to protect
everyone else on the train that never
even meant to my mind so that's why I'm
asking you do you have specific footage
of him threatening the very people who
subdued and ended up killing him but why
does that matter I don't think there is
footage
well then that's all I wanted to know
what does that have to do with what I
said that's why I understand your your
thoughts because I would think that the
proportionality being that you ended up
killing them even if that was not your
intent I understand that you don't think
he intended to do that fine but even if
that was it were they like
threats to him in the immediate like
present where were they on the verge of
committing an act of violence towards
him that required proportional violence
that ended up in death but it's not a
requirement someone threatens you for
you to act in defense of others
right so your question is kind of in in
an unnecessary Direction and I'll
elaborate if you're on a train and
you're trapped in a box and someone is
threatening violence then yeah you're a
victim because so I've been a victim
multiple times
absolutely okay it's the craziest thing
to me I don't feel like a victim I've
never been hurt I never was hurt by
people who are going through those kind
of other people have been I I'm not
saying they haven't I'm not I'm not
saying this 25 people are pushed in
front of trains okay so these 25 people
were pushing from trains how is that
directly related were these people also
going through episodes were they also
people who were homeless did they have
mental illness like I I would say
shoving someone in front of a train at
random is like going through an episode
you know what I mean the correlation is
that crime and murder on the subway has
been increasing or has at least been a
parent in the Press but I don't see you
caring about it at all until it's the
aggressor who gets who gets killed no
one I think on the left is going to
defend this stat that you're playing in
prison for finally saying stop killing
people this is like Tim if I approach to
you today and I was like hey do you know
what goes on in Rikers Island have any
of you done a show on what happens at
Rikers Island how they hold people in
Rikers Island do you know what we not
Rikers Island specifically but we talk
about prison reform all the time okay do
you know about bail reform and the fact
that people die in Rikers Island waiting
waiting to have their day in court
because they can't afford it and we've
talked about it and you've done entire
shows on that and you've talked about
how people literally die in prison yeah
while they're waiting for that we
talked about terrible okay so we talked
actually talked about one guy who got
wrongly arrested lost his job was kicked
out of his apartment went to Rikers for
three months only to be released and
then told sorry there's nothing you can
do about it the city owes him nothing
because they considered the prosecution
not to be malicious but this is the
problem man like
we we we talk about stuff like this all
the time but example you just gave me
was not me talking about the systemic
problem of people who are poor being in
righteousness before they get to trial
they die before they get they're not
released you just gave me a story of
someone who was released an example of a
specific show we've actually talked
about someone wrongly held and had their
life destroyed okay now of course we can
we can we can go on further and say yes
people have died yes the system is
corrupt and my point is this when we
talk about stuff like this like wow in
October we talked about 25 people being
pushed in front of push in front of
train cars you guys just all over
us and ignore these problems then
finally when when three guys ignoring
this I told you no one's on the other
side of this no no no no it is your
protest where's your protest where's my
protest yeah where's your brother
where's your Rikers protest we headed on
the show but you did a protest you did
an actual protested we don't go on the
streets ever but I'm not I'm not blaming
you for not talking about the Tim
because this is like this is the problem
of like you are judging someone based on
absence based on your absence of caring
about something why haven't you talked
about this Lance the fact that you
haven't talked about this means that you
don't care about that that's not that's
not true though that's not that's the
implication of what you're saying right
now my implication is instead of helping
us deal with this when we talk about it
you make up garbage about us and then
post nonsense on the internet what if I
brought up garbage about people pushing
people to trains this is the most random
talking about you saying I'm saying you
you don't talk about it right I'm not
criticizing you for not talking about
I'm saying finally when there are people
who are like we've had 25 people push in
front of trains we've had two of them
killed I'm not gonna let this person
hurt somebody it's y'all saying that
person should go to prison
so how is that solving the problem you
guys are making it worse thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time